[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to cosmic wonder where we
talk about all things relating to the
MCU and today we have some pretty big
news to talk about in less than 10 days
Disney is having a special event where
they're going to talk about their
upcoming Disney Plus projects and during
this event some key executives from
Marvel and Star Wars are going to be
there to talk about future projects now
when we think of key executives over at
Marvel Studios we think about Kevin
Feige the president and not to mention
the now CEO of Marvel Entertainment the
chief creative officer this title gave
him creative control over all of the
shows that are going to be produced
under Marvel so Kevin Feige is expected
to be at this event so let's break down
what we can expect if you're new be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 so in about a
week Disney is hosting a Disney Plus
launch event on March 5th in London now
this launch event is because Europe is
finally getting Disney Plus on March
24th now it's reported that Marvel is
going to get their own time and do their
own presentation and during this
presentation they're going to talk about
all of their upcoming Disney Plus shows
and according to Charles Murphy from
Murphy's multiverse comm Marvel Studios
will likely update its 2021 release
schedule which should include new
release dates for Loki what if and
Hawkeye and potentially dates for miss
Marvel she-hulk and Moon Knight so we
could be getting some phase 5 reveals
during this event now keep in mind it is
a Disney Plus event not a Marvel
exclusive event so when Marvel takes the
stage for their presentation they're
only going to be talking about upcoming
Marvel Disney Plus shows and if you're
not aware we do have a lot of them right
now we have a 1 division Loki the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier Marvel Studios
what if Hawkeye is finally back on track
and of course she-hulk Moon Knight and
Miss Marvel now we've already seen a
little teaser for Falcon in the Winter
Soldier 1 division and Loki but it has
been reported by the Twitter account MCU
source that we are going to be getting
30-second teasers for both 1 division
and a falcon and the Winter Soldier
series at this event so if this report
ends up
being true we should be getting two new
teaser trailers for phase four projects
on March 5th and it makes sense because
these are going to be the first to
Disney Plus shows that we're going to be
getting and if they do happen to reveal
the release dates for Miss Marvel Moon
Knight and she hoped that these will be
the first reveals of the phase of five
slate because it's very unlikely with
everything that phase four has jammed in
it already that these three projects are
going to be a part of phase four so big
things are said to be coming from this
Disney Plus launch event that is less
than a week away let me know which
Disney Plus Marvel show you're most
excited about in the comments down below
don't forget to leave a like on the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
any MCU news and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof